hey
can you tell me why you're out here
today right today's to support my meal
bowl Jamal on his birthday mother's been
incarcerated for a long time and more
importantly we're here to occupy the
Justice Department for all political
prisoners and all victims of this racist
state that we have a head over the last
30 years crime has decreased by our
incarceration rates have increased we
need to bring more awareness to the
issue of mass incarceration my goal is
to make Mumia abu-jamal a household name
I'm a big supporter of Mumia abu-jamal
first of all and also I am really
against the way that the so-called
justice system treats people of color in
our in our in our country I'm here to
ask President Barack Obama genet mamiya
go he never committed a crime he was our
scholar our intellectual I have a great
thinker for the race of her people you
have people that hear that from
different denominations or different
groups I even seen some socialists and
communists back there there is no quote
unquote perfect society unless we I
really end capitalism we're in
patriarchy bring about matriarchy and
eco socialism society based on the
subordination and submission of humans
to mother earth you're holding a workers
world party side you are you aware that
the workers world party is a supporter
of the North Korean regime which has the
death penalty no actually I didn't know
that
I went to Cuba myself and I feel like
Cuba certainly an example of a country
that has far less racism than the u.s.
yeah I gotta ask though in Cuba do they
have fair trials absolutely absolutely
and they have fair elections John base
their fair elections they definitely
have fair elections and then the people
of Cuba decide in their soft by far
higher turnout voter turnout in favor of
license is it a suspiciously high voter
turnout no it's about ninety percent
because people are engaged and they care
about what's happy and they know their
elections aren't rig are you
disappointed in Obama and eric holder at
all I can't be disappointed in people
who function in the way that they have
always functioned so it is what it is
I'm you know no more disappointed than I
wasn't Bush Obama is a politician who
need votes from white people I
understand his methods and motives I do
not blame Barack Obama and I do not
blame eric holder for a condition that's
been here for hundreds of years I have a
great idea everybody who works for the
justice system the Justice Department
police judges prosecutors shall all
mandatorily have to spend 24 hours in
jail so they understand the death trap
they send their people to we can win we
shall win we can win we shall win we
can't man we can when we will perform to
free up your jeweler cream too I jordam
up thank you for your luck